erschreckende bilder von einer
partynacht in frankfurt am main
500 bis 800 chaoten randalieren auf dem
opernplatz
sie werfen flaschen die polizei ist
zunächst machtlos
mit schutzausrüstung und schildern
versuchen die beamten den aufstand
aufzulösen
doch sie werden immer wieder
zurückgedrängt bei dieser und weiter auf
der kollegen und kolleginnen mit
flaschen geworfen und zwar so massiv
dass diese polizei hätten mehrfach
anhalten mussten um sich zu schützen um
sich zu positionieren die schüsse gehört
zu nehmen und und erst dann eben weiter
agieren konnten als dann diese hagel von
stahl von flaschenwürfen dann weniger
geworden sind und dass ich besonders
erschreckend finde alle anderen noch
dort verbliebenen circa 500 bis 800
personen begannen dann zu johlen und
beifall zu klatschen wenn flaschen die
kollegen getroffen haben
insgesamt fünf beamte werden verletzt 39
personen festgenommen die meute
hinterlässt einen sachschaden von
mehreren tausend euro
dabei hatte die partie nach zunächst
friedlich begonnen tausende treffen sich
am abend zum feiern in der frankfurter
innenstadt doch gegen 1 uhr kommt es am
opernplatz zu einer massenschlägerei mit
30 beteiligten
die stimmung hat sich dann weiter an
haben ganz normal angefangen den platz
räumen
also ich hab es auch gegen das team
finden und schlagstöcken unterwegs wagen
aber nicht so krass angewendet oder
eingesetzt und haben die es bei dem
platz ihr geräumt und die polizei hat
hier vor ort abgeriegelt und dort aber
sie kamen immer wieder stück von der die
stoffe und haben die polizisten mit
flaschen beworfen
erst mit der verstärkung der
bundespolizei kann die situation geklärt
werden
durch die korona pandemie gehen vor
allem am wochenende viele zu feiern auf
die straßen
bleibt zu hoffen dass solche partybilder
die ausnahme bleibt mir jetzt aus
frankfurt zugeschaltet jessica verleih
jessica war denn die party am anfang
überhaupt legal
na ja es ist so die klubs ins tor
solange alles wonach porsche
angesprochen werden man mindestabstand
von anhalt meter am main hätten versucht
das war jetzt nicht unbedingt nach einem
haufen sich zusammen bummelt aufgesetzt
hat dann ist das schon erlaubt
der ganze umgebung auf einen festen
versammeln sich die leute seit wochen
und feiern das land immer friedlich da
war das einzige problem was der hat
nämlich die ganze flasche und den müll
der hier sieht dann wurden hier tausende
von müll von aufgestellt um diesem
problem entgegenzuwirken aber die wurden
dann leider auch als bach ja die bilder
haben wir gerade gesehen wie extrem ist
dann gestern ausgeartet ist 9 und 3 und
39 festnahm
was kannst du uns über diese chaoten
sagen sie sollen zwischen 17 und 23
jahre alt gewesen sein nur neun von
ihnen waren aus frankfurt kam aus der
umgebung also aus limburg hanau
offenbach heidelberg haben wir wollten
offensichtlich party macht mit ihren
freundlich und dann ist es ausgeartet
ein hauptteil migrationshintergrund und
sie waren stark betrunken und sehr sehr
sehr gut weiß man schon bis jetzt mit
den 39 festgenommenen randalierern
weitergeht
heute morgen beide stand es bereits 31
wieder frei gelassen wurden und jetzt
vor kurzem wurden auch die letzten acht
verdächtige wieder freigelassen
ein klassiker für dieses update
dankeschön